if Islam is inherently violent why isn't
every single Muslim in the world that is
nearly two billion people violent and
engaged in Acts of terrorism this
question represents one of Islam's most
popular defenses because not all Muslims
are violent and tolerant or sponsored
terrorism a true statement Islam itself
must be innocent let's briefly consider
this logic first there are in fact many
people who identify themselves as
Muslims but who do not necessarily
adhere to or support Islam's more
supremacist and intolerant doctrines if
you've ever lived in a Muslim majority
Nation as I have you would know this to
be true the all important question is
what do such Muslims represent are they
following a legitimate moderate version
of Islam one more authentic than the
radical variety that's what all the
Talking Heads would have us believe
let's try to answer this question by
analogy German Nazism is a widely
condemned ideology due to its
supremacist elements but the fact is
many Germans who were members or
supporters of the Nazi party were good
people they did not believe in
persecuting Jews and other non-aryans
and some even helped them Escape at no
small risk to themselves consider Oscar
Schindler a German and formal member of
the Nazi party he went to Great Lengths
to save Jews from Slaughter how do we
reconcile his Good Deed with his bad
Creed was Schindler practicing a
legitimate moderate form of Nazism or is
it more reasonable to say that he
subscribed to some tenants of nation
socialism but when it came to killing
fellow humans in the name of a
supremacist ideology his Humanity Rose
above his allegiance to Nazism indeed
many Germans joined or supported the
National Socialist Party more because it
was the winning party one that offered
hope and less because of its theories
ideological and racial that said other
Germans joined the na Nazi party
precisely because of its supremacist
theories and we're only too happy to see
subhumans
eliminated now now consider how this
analogy applies to Islam and Muslims
first unlike most Germans who chose to
join or support the Nazi party the
overwhelming majority of Muslims around
the world were simply born into Islam
they had no choice many of these Muslims
know the bare minimum about Islam the
Five Pillars and are ignorant of Islam's
supremacist theories add Islam's
apostasy law to the mix leaving Islam
can earn the death penalty and it
becomes clear that there are many
nominal Muslims out there who simply do
not want to rock the boat that said
there are also a great many Muslims who
know exactly what Islam teaches
including Eternal hate for and War on
the cfer or the Infidel and who happily
follow it precisely because of these
teachings in both Nazism and Islam we
have a supremacist ideology on the one
hand and people who find themselves
associated with this ideology on the
other from those born into it to those
who join it for its temporal Boon to
those who are sincere and Ardent
Believers the all important difference
is this when it comes to Nazism the
world is agreed that it is a supremacist
ideology those who followed it to the
core were the bad guys as for the good
Nazis who helped shelter persecuted Jews
and performed other altruistic Deeds the
world acknowledges that they were not
following a moderate form of Nazism but
that their commitment to Nazism was
obviously less than total this is the
correct Paradigm for understanding the
relationship between Islam and Muslims
Islam does contain violent supremacist
doctrines this is a simple fact those
who follow it to the core were and are
the bad guys the radicals the terrorists
still there are good Muslims yet they
are good and not because they follow a
good or moderate Islam but because they
are not committed to Islam in the first
place put differently was Oscar
Schindler's altruism a product of
moderate Nazism or was it done in spite
of Nazism altogether clearly the latter
in the same manner if a Muslim say
treats a non-muslim with dignity and
equality is he doing so because He
follows a legitimate brand of moderate
Islam or is he doing so in spite of
Islam because his own sense of decency
compels him considering that Islamic law
is unequivocally clear that non-muslims
are to be hated fought and killed or at
least subjugated as in Quran 9:29
clearly any Muslim who treats
non-muslims with equality is behaving
against Islam so why is the West unable
to apply this Nazi Paradigm to the
question of Islam and Muslims why is it
able to acknowledge that Islamic
teachings are inherently violent
intolerant and in a word supremacist
though obviously not all Muslims are
literally following these teachings just
like not all members of any religion are
literally following the teachings of
their faith this question becomes even
more pressing when one realizes that for
well over a millennium the West was
convinced that Islam is inherently
violent and intolerant as we saw in a
recent video from the dawn of Islam up
until very recently all of the West
luminaries from John of Damascus born in
675 to Winston Churchill who died in
1965 depicted Islam as a violent Creed
that thrives on conquering plundering
and subjugating the other the problem
today is that the establishment Academia
mainstream media politicians and all the
other Talking Heads have made it an
established or rather establishment fact
that Islam is just like every other
religion therefore the religion itself
not just some of its practitioners who
can easily be dismissed as radicals
must at all costs be shielded from
criticism the point here is that
identifying the negative elements of an
ideology and condemning it accordingly
is not so difficult we've already done
so with Nazism and other ideologies and
Cults and we know the difference between
those who follow such supremacist
ideologies the bad guys and those who
find themselves as casual uncommitted
members good or neutral people iner
times when Common Sense could vent and
breathe this analogy would have been
deemed superfluous in our times however
where lots of woke garbage is
disseminated far and wide Common Sense
must be methodically spelled out as I am
doing here now yes an ideology religion
can be accepted as bad and no many of
its adherence need not be bad for the
reasons I just laid out this I submit to
you is the most objective way to
understand the relationship between
Islam as a body of teachings and Muslims
as individual people the religion is
inherently divisive intolerant violent
and supremacist as are all those Muslims
who follow it though obviously not every
single one of them does